et tout autre sujet à présent c'est le
retour des épidémies hivernales la
grippe mais aussi la gastro entérite
mercredi 20 janvier le réseau de
surveillance sentinelles composé de 1300
médecins généralistes libéraux annoncé
que le seuil épidémique de la gastro
entérite et ait été atteint en france
métropolitaine
ce seuil est alain tatin lorsque 193
personnes sont malades pour 100000
habitants la semaine dernière la france
étaient encore concernés puisqu'il y
avait 247 cas pour 100000 habitants du
docteur fleury médecins à quoi lumière
nous en explique les raisons
la première manière de s'en prémunir
c'est justement une des mesures de
protection par rapport à ça des mesures
d'hygiène celmo cardinal par rapport à
la gastro et dans la toute première
mesure pour s'en protéger
c'est tout banalement le lavage des
mains de lavage donc bien bien soigneux
le brassage disons-le etc
le virus ça s'appelle à rotavirus est
assez banal et donc mais qui est très
résistant et donc ils résistent assez
facilement à l'extérieur de l'organisme
est donc mis aux nues il a le temps de
se transmettre